uh it's hot and it's getting hotter
how's london coping
well we are as a global city we suffer
from what's called the urban heat island
effect which means it's hotter in london
than other parts of the country and it
feels hotter as well
the met office for the first time in its
history issued the level four red
warning and the chief medical officer
advised it's not just the elderly and
those who are vulnerable who will suffer
the effects of this excessive heat but
all of us
and so so far things are running okay in
our city because people are doing the
right thing
uh they're only using public transport
if it's essential for them to do so
uh they're not ringing nine or nine
unless it's an emergency and it's really
important we do we can today and
tomorrow to make sure we get through
this healthy one and
as well as we can be
we should be doing better though
shouldn't we we're here about schools
potentially closing trains not running
it's summer it gets hot we should be
prepared
well that's the classic mistake to make
this is not normal temperatures for a
summer in our city and our country
records are going to be broken uh this
year
40 degrees is not normal it's one of the
consequences by the way of uh climate
change it's beggars belief by the way
none of those running to be the next
prime minister seem to care about this
issue we would have these temperatures
of you know north of 35 degrees one once
every 300 years in previous decades now
it's once every three years and that's
why we have to adapt now because i'm
afraid this may become the norm rather
than the exception but we aren't ready
for these temperatures we aren't
prepared we're not used to them and
that's why people should be careful
you're not on holiday now uh you're in
this country these temperatures are
excessive please be careful carry water
if you're out and about change your
normal routines don't go out between
11am and 3pm the hottest parts of the
day and the other problem we have is it
stays hot and it stays hot in the
evenings as well so you don't cool off
in the evenings that's why it's really
important not to fall for the sunshine
outside your window if you've got to
call home think about staying indoors
given that we could well see days like
this appearing more frequently what is
london doing what are you doing to make
sure that facilities in the capital to
make sure that transport in the capital
will be able to cope in future
so the good news is that the new stuff
we're building so the new elizabeth line
air conditioned
new buildings were building have cooling
systems reliable renewable energies uh
you know are insulated and so forth the
key challenge is to retrofit in other
words adapt the buildings we already
have adapt the public transport we
already have and we're trying to work
with the government to make sure the new
buses are not just fully electric
but are cooler in the summer a warm in
the winter to persuade the government to
invest in buildings which creates jobs
by the way we need people to insulate
buildings to have double glazing to have
energy efficient buildings so it's a
good way of making sure we're ready to
deal with these temperatures but also it
creates jobs as well
yeah
bring it back to the present some unions
calling for a maximum workplace
temperature meaning employees get
flexible conditions if the workplace uh
hits a a certain temperature 25 degrees
celsius or whatever it may be
is that a good idea or is that more
nanny state
well no i think i think we've got to be
looking at certain industries i mean for
example some council says have and i
support this asked their refuge
collectors to just start a bit earlier
uh stood out in the sun when it's so you
know really really dangerous some
construction workers i know are starting
early today uh making sure they're not
in the sun when it's really really hot
we've got to adapt our working practices
because of these temperatures they're
not normal and so we can't rely upon
business as usual uh we've got two days
of temperatures at or above 40 degrees
never before have we had that in our
country the met office has never before
issued the level 4 uh red warning never
before have you got a medical experts
advising all of us not just the elderly
and vulnerable to be cognizant be aware
take steps to avoid getting unwell these
are exceptional circumstances which
require exceptional measures
yeah the temperature uh just crept up
again hottest place in the uk now rittle
in essex 32.3
degrees celsius the deputy prime
minister dominic raab has said that
people should stay hydrated but also
should be resilient and enjoy the
sunshine i mean he's got a point hasn't
he
well he has if you're like dominic rob
and have an air-conditioned office
and are driven in an air conditioned car
from home to the office for everybody
else that's not the life that they
lead that's why it's really important to
make sure yes you wear sunscreen you
stay hydrated carry around water with
you make sure you refill your bottle
keep an eye for the elderly those living
by themselves don't assume and because
you're the deputy prime minister and
you've got a hunky-dory life everybody
else has the same life they don't
um just finally uh pollution a big
problem in the capital and of course the
hot weather means those levels are going
up as well
absolutely uh we know uh that in a cable
city like london not only do we have the
the urban heat island effect but also
air pollution can get worse imperial
college have confirmed uh we're at the
higher level now for air pollution if
you're somebody like me who's got you
know asthma it can be real challenge but
also people without health issues can
suffer as a consequence of the poor air
pollution and so if you've got a child
in a buggy don't take them out during
the day time don't do strenuous exercise
when when the heat is hot but also when
the air pollution is at its worst just
for two days be sensible use your common
sense go to the office website go to the
city hall website look at the best
possible advice to keep yourself safe
your family safe and those vulnerable
neighbors safe as well
okay we must leave it there thank you
very much for your time sadiq khan mayor
of london